my guest tonight start on hbo's
trueblood he also played uh
big dick richie stole my nickname
in the uh magic mike movies his latest
movie
arch enemy is available on demand
beginning tomorrow please welcome our
friend
joe mangano how are you joe hey conan
i'm great good to see you
uh first of all i want to say i love
that wolf painting behind you
when you have the combination of the
wolf
your buzz cut your and and then that
evil
beard you were a fierce fierce guy on
zoom
you were the fiercest zoom call i've
ever had fantastic
yes yes it's
it's amazing um can you know where i
could get a wolf
painting i need a wolf painting behind
me because
this this isn't doing it i need that
fierce yelling wolf
you know what's crazy i had this
commission back in the true blood days
this was my wolf
from true blood my wolf thunder that i
used to transform into
i had a bunch of pictures i took a bunch
of pictures of them and sent them off to
a painter that i was introduced to and
and this came out this is a one-of-one
but
it's funny you say that because i could
just call that painter up and have them
paint you one
yeah but i don't think a wolf works for
you i think i need a frightened
uh lemur you know like a friend i've got
an
idea i've got an idea oh
who's this this is wait this is your new
this is your dog bubbles is that right
yeah that's right this is bubbles this
is bubbles bubbles is
how long have you had bubbles for about
a year and a half
look at the wolf is trying to eat
bubbles that's the optical illusion
right now
bubbles is running from but that's your
painting this is your painting i have a
boyfriend
i'm more of a bubbles guy what a cute
let's talk about bubbles for a second
because
uh i know you post a lot of photos of
bubbles
you've got this picture you put up
of um bubbles your dog sort of as baby
yoda
very nice do they get along uh she
doesn't really like
baby yoda i think she's uh maybe jealous
of baby yoda
that maybe we're gonna hug baby yoda and
feed baby yoda more than her
it's gonna start taking up more
attention so there's a rivalry brewing
between
the the two i understand there's another
rivalry which is
correct me if i'm wrong uh that bubbles
kind of prefers you to sophia is that
right
yeah that's right uh chihuahuas are
notorious
for just picking somebody's that they
pick a person
and she picked me right away when the
shelter brought her over she actually
jumped away from the shelter people ran
over to me to pick her up
and then started growling at the people
from the shelter like go away
and then sophia tried to grab her she
growled at sophia
really so bubbles doesn't like sophia
but prefers you
she likes sophia now sophia is uh
feeds her a lot and uh and she likes
that so anytime sophia's in the kitchen
she'll run around because she knows
there's gonna be some food
but otherwise yeah it's uh it's uh
sophia's been a little bit jealous yeah
you know
um i have to say uh joe i can relate
because the first time i met you guys
my immediate attraction was to you and i
was very hostile to sophia
they say that tall irish people
pick someone and then you're their
person
yes and i i totally understand that
um so i i actually i've
a lot of people out there they don't
know that i i sometimes i will hold
conan like this conan will give me his
belly
and i will just rub conan's belly and
feed him treats
whenever i get up tight everyone in my
world says
you gotta go to joe's house and let him
hold you and rub your belly and i do
and i immediately calm down yes yes
yeah it runs that way yeah yeah yeah
yeah
let's uh
hey let's talk about your look i love
this look by the way
this is you can pull that off i don't
think i could pull that off
are you sure i mean i i don't know i
think uh you know it's interesting when
you're this tall
and you're bald and you have a big
goatee people treat you differently
people are oh they're afraid of you
right yeah
they're afraid the baldness and the
devil the devil goatee
you got all that going for you uh you
look like someone who just emerged from
hell
and is here for vengeance i wonder if we
could we could actually do that right
now
like kind of you know
[Laughter]
conan
[Laughter]
you you know i want to ask you about
this because you just brought it to mind
i know that you are
speaking about other worlds netherworlds
you're a big dungeons and dragons guy
i mean you take this very seriously and
you
run a dnd game that a lot of celebrities
like
a-list celebrities are in your dnd game
is that correct
this is correct yes that is correct
what is your yeah it's a lot of fun you
know uh all of us used to play when we
were younger
um it was instrumental for a lot of us
uh in terms of what we wanted doing for
a career
you know for me as an actor uh you know
character building writing backstories i
was doing this stuff before
i even started acting or even understood
that that was something you could do for
a profession
and you know certainly that the guys who
created game of thrones
play in my group certainly that was that
was instrumental for them in creating
long-form storytelling within a fantasy
world i mean
with dragons and you know archetypical
warriors and fighters and and wizards
and things like that
um but also you you might not know that
like my trainer
of the past 10 years who is a crossfit
champion was also huge into dundas and
dragons the big show
seven foot four i know a big show uh
he's been on my show
countless times i love that guy so big
big
show is in my dnd group and would
charter flights from florida
to come in on friday to play and and
also
vince vaughn is in your group vince
vaughn is in my group
tom morello guitar god tom morello uh
all
super like hardcore serious
uh when when we were younger about uh d
d and i got the idea to to start playing
again
and it's become this thing that like all
of us kind of live for during the week
to get to friday to play this game and
see each other and you know
talk smack and roll dice and yell at
each other and
and uh it's so much fun and you are a
dungeon master
i'm told which means you hold a great
deal of
power and knowledge as dungeon master in
the d d world correct
yes yes um yes uh yes yes conan
um yeah no i i so i'm kind of the i'm
like a show runner
of our show where you know say dan
and dave for game of thrones were
responsible for coming up with the story
line and
and where the plot was going to go and
then who all the characters are they're
going to step in and interact with the
main characters
i'm that person so i also do all of the
voices for all of those characters oh
you do the voices
i do voices yeah so anytime they meet a
new character
uh i i do the voice of that character if
they go to a store or a blacksmith's
shop or you know an an alchemist shop
um you know they might find someone who
you know
um hi instead what can i get you in you
know and it's like these two people from
pittsburgh he's like talking to him
about like
you know their blacksmith needs you know
against need a great sword in that yeah
we can we can uh we can knock one of
them out for you come on back
tomorrow morning i love that these guys
that run this magical shop are from
pittsburgh
yeah yeah so they keep going back to the
shop to make me do the voice or
for example there was a seagull there's
a there's like a character in the
in the group who can speak to animals so
he thinks it's really funny
to make me do voices for all these
different animals so he always wants to
talk to every animal he can find
you know is there a you know oh i want
to talk to the seagull you know the
seagull
is really unimpressed with everything
they've done you know i thought you'd be
dead by now this is crazy
and you know christian christian chris
walken is the seagull
his name is christopher squaken
[Laughter]
and so he'll fly around and meet them or
you know hey i want to talk to that
squirrel and see if the squirrel saw
anyone run through the forest and it's
like
okay here we go now oh hi what's going
on guys that's crazy
yeah i saw a couple people run by here
earlier and you know you're
now you're the satanic christmas animals
from south park
so where would um let's say i was in
this game
you know let's pretend i'm an a-lister
and i'm in this game
uh what animal would i be what what
would you see me
being do you see i mean you're the
showrunner you're the
dungeon master what would i do what
would i be
uh like animal-wise or character-wise
because
you could be you could be a wiz well
like let me ask you a question like
you know would you would you rather
fight with a sword and be kind of some
kind of you know conan the barbarian s
character or are you more like a wizard
or someone who casts spells yeah i don't
want to
personally be in any danger so i like
the idea of being
far away from the actual fighting and
maybe uh
i'm doing incantations or maybe just
making threatening phone calls
but i'm not someone who's actually in
the nothing i don't have a sword or a
weapon i can't get hurt
i like the threatening phone call idea
because there's spells where you could
like
speak into someone's brain so you could
just send
evil messages into people's brain from
way in the back that's what i do
here at the late night show with people
that work with me
you know is for years i just writers
anyone who works on the show i'm
constantly
i'm playing with their minds uh i'm
passive-aggressive
um you know that gets my i think that's
my talent
yelling at andy maybe i don't know
that's right people don't know this but
when we started the
interview just be as we were about to
start and we were ready to go
andy was right back here talking as loud
as humanly possible
and you were on the line and i was like
andy and they sucked
up and he started yelling back at me and
you were loving it
you were enjoying well it was like when
you're when you're a kid and you're on
the phone with your friend
and mom leave me alone you know they
start screaming at their mom
it was like one of those where you got
to see our real
andy are you back there did he take off
where does he go
he's out in the alley like smoking weed
it's unbelievable
it's incredible this is such an
unprofessional organization he was back
there yelling and making noise
but i think he did leave i think he's in
the alley outside the theater
40 chance he's high right is that right
yeah what's a gateway drug the the the
you know smoking the weed i mean next
thing you know
andy's on heroin meth something yeah and
then
next thing you know he's playing
dungeons and dragons so i mean
you gotta be careful that's how it works
uh i love this i love that now when you
play dungeons and dragons do you guys
trash talk
each other is that a game where you can
trash talk like let's say you and vince
vaughn do you guys get into it
yeah in fact vince's character
was attempting to buy a magic carpet
so in the game there's like a there was
a shop you know what kind of getchance
and then he came in and uh you know i'd
like a magic carpet and all of a sudden
he got into this
it was like a used car battle you know
where he was trying to work me down
over this used magic carpet and i was
this used magic carpet salesman that was
like
you know trying to sell vince on the
fact that he needs the bigger model
he needs to spend a little more money
and he's trying to work me down the road
it went on for five to ten minutes this
improv between
vince's character and my used magic
carpet salesman
and everyone in the room was screaming
and laughing and on the ground
crying my question is where's sophia
when all this is happening
you're married to one of the most
beautiful women in the world
one of the sexiest women to have ever
lived and you're in a room
playing dungeons and dragons where is
she
does she approve of all of this
well here's the thing coded she knows
where i am
i'm i'm not out in a back alley getting
in trouble
yeah okay all right right so she always
knows it every time where you are and
what you're up to
she knows where i am yeah and i think
that's the most important thing
uh let's talk about arch enemy you play
this this is my favorite
character name uh a great character but
also great character name
max fist
yes yes take it easy this is a show
primarily for children so let's tone it
down
i didn't dip it in the vat of crisco
[Laughter]
so i was trying to keep it clean i was
just giving you
that this is an independent film
and there's intense action that's got to
be difficult i would think it adds to
the adrenaline when you're shooting
these action scenes and it has to be
that precise and you've got to get it
right
and there's no oh don't worry the
computers will clean this up later on
you know
yeah there's no computer to clean it up
later on that's
it i i have to get it practically but i
really love that kind of
tightrope walking and and i actually
enjoy it i like those steaks
all right let's take a look at this
moment from arch enemy
there's a fragment of the cosmic blood
in this it's a synthetic analog
but a scent a memory a molecule
was given power power to experience the
universe for everyone
all of the timelines all at once all
coursing through my mind
so that i could save them all are you
saying that the cosmic blood is
methamphetamine maybe i haven't tried
hard enough
it allows me to go through what i pull
through the molecules do you understand
me
through the molecules
and we're back okay for people that
don't know
my character max fist has delusions
he he thinks he's from another dimension
and in this dimension
he was something equivalent to like a
superman or the superhero
right but as you can see from the clip
uh he might just be having a psychotic
episode
from nephews uh he's a homeless man who
is addicted to meth and alcohol and
lives in a tent
uh and has these delusions of being from
a different dimension
um but yes that is uh that's that's him
having a psychotic
episode or a breakdown on his way to
uh go on an attempted murder spree so i
think there's a lot to unpack there
i had a meth coach on set with me
to show me how to do meth you could have
just gone method
and been on meth i i could have
that's where math comes from method
actors yeah math actors are really
pretty much on meth so
you know it's basically uh the plot to
mary poppins
you know that's uh the the they they
remade it it's quite different than the
one spoonful of sugar
uh there's a double meaning there yeah
exactly
joe uh my best to you for the holidays
uh my best to your uh your lovely bride
and to bubbles
i love bubbles yes yes
happy holidays conan from the tiny the
little christmas bear
all right there is uh joe manganiello
and uh
of course bubbles and uh you guys take
care